goldi hor you know actress goldi H
little little bit eccentric Goldie hon
has claimed that not only has she seen
UFOs but she's actually encountered them
and they touched her
face
so Goldie H is in the camp of Matt Walsh
on the aliens
question uh the uh serious theologians
and philosophers and rational people
throughout all of history are they're in
my camp on the alien question goldi hon
is in the sweet Daddy's Camp uh here's
what goldi hon said she said there was a
time when you know there was a lot of
UFO sightings I remember so clearly I
went outside my door and I sat on a
little Edge and I looked up at the dark
sky and I saw all these stars and all I
could think of was how far does this go
how little are we are we the only planet
in this whole wide universe that has
life on it I said I know you're out
there I know we're not alone and I would
like to meet you one day now hold on
hold on the way she's talking to these
aliens is not the way you would talk to
aliens if aliens were really just beings
physical beings from some other
planet because they probably couldn't
hear her right because she's
not because physical beings are
constrained by physics the way she's
talking to these aliens is the way you
would talk to angels or demons who are
pure Spirit who are not confined by
physical
laws right I don't when I'm trying to
talk to Ben Davies well that's a bad
example because I have a microphone
phone sitting right here at my desk but
if I were to talk to Jeremy who's in
Hungary right now and I said Jeremy I
know you can hear me he wouldn't be able
to hear me because he's not within the
proximity of my physical voice and he
doesn't listen to my show so if I were
talking to an angel though I could say I
know you hear me and uh I would have a
greater cause to think that the angel
could hear me because angels are pure
Spirit they're all
around This Woman's talking like she's
talking to Angels or demons she goes on
she say I know you're out there I want
to meet you she invites them in then she
says later on I get this high-pitched
sound in my ear it was this high high
frequency she was taking a nap in her
car she looks out the window and there's
these two or three triangular shaped
heads on little bodies they were silver
in color slash for a mouth tiny little
nose no ears they were pointing at me
pointing at me in the car as if they
were discussing me like I was a subject
and they were droning I was paralyzed
and I thought oh my God I want to get up
I didn't know if it was real or not real
then she burst out of the state of
paralysis and said it was like bursting
out of a force field so there two things
that this could be and they're not
necessarily mutually exclusive what this
could be at a physical explanation is
that it could be sleep paralysis which
maybe you've had I've had sleep
paralysis where you wake up but you
can't move you're still kind of asleep
but you're you're you think you're awake
and you have hallucinations I've only
experienced this I don't know a couple
two or three times maybe but you you can
sometimes hear something I've never
visually hallucinated but I've heard
things in the state of sleep paralysis
and then it's kind of scary and then you
kind of snap snap out of it you can move
again and uh it's fine there is a
spiritual answer here too which is it
could be that she was just looking at
demons they sound a lot like demons and
they kind of talk they her experience of
it sounds like how everyone's described
demons for all of human history so it
could be that
too either way though not a lot of
strong evidence that it's aliens and
either way not not the sort of thing
that you want to
invite your move Mr Walsh right now go
to genucell.com NES our friends over at
Jus cell have launched a new product
called genus cell 3 which works fast on
your under eye bags and puffiness genus
cell 3 uses advanced technology to
deliver complex vitamins and minerals
directly to your face for instant
hydration it's like Gatorade for your
skin this new genus cell technology
keeps your skin looking young and
healthy for years to come the genus cell
fall Classics package also includes a
jawline treatment for a more firm neck
and jawline it also includes genus cells
anti wrinkle moisturizer and deep
Firming Serum of course any genus cell
Luxury Box is not complete without the
great genus cell XV anti-wrinkle
moisturizer and their world famous deep
Firming Serum get your skin ready for
the cold and dry weather if you do not
look and feel your absolute best you'll
get your money back no questions asked
go to jas.com
kwes or you can call 800 skin 211 for
extra discounts on this amazing fall
package get results in 12 hours or less
the immediate effects are included for
free jus.com
Wes or call 800 skin SK n211 since coid
especially more and more people have
been taking their kids out of the
schools most of the public schools even
some of the private schools and
homeschooling them and homeschooling
especially when I was a kid
homeschooling was a thing that just
those weird conservative Christians did
that's not the sort of thing that normal
Posh clubbable people would do well well
now a lot of people are homeschooling
why is this the Washington Post is just
engaged in an examination of this I say
we're trying to figure it out number one
even as the pandemic eased homeschooling
persisted so they tried it out because
of Co but then they stuck with it they
didn't just send the kids back to school
when the school's reopened homeschooling
comes off as
Fringe you well it used to be Fringe now
that is no longer
the
case homeschooling is on the rise in all
sorts of places not just down south not
just in those hillbilly deplorable
irredeemable countries of the Trump boat
and whatever the Liberals think it's all
over the place religion is no longer the
the sole driver of it used to be just
Christian conservatives now people who
are not conservative people who are not
Christian are sending their kids to or
or keeping their kids home and
homeschooling them also homeschoolers
are more diverse than ever racially and
across all sorts of demographics and
then here's an interesting one parents
do less and less of the
teaching meaning they'll they'll form
little pods with different families and
sometimes they'll form even miniature
schools and then that will but but it
will be separate from a public school
and it'll be separate even from the the
private schools so what does this mean
it means this is the fastest growing
part of the US education system as even
the Washington Post
found and it means that it'll probably
persist but that last part I think is
key here because I'd compare it to
Airbnb
remember people used to stay at these
things called hotels and motels that's
where if you were out of town and
traveling somewhere and you needed a
place to stay You'd Stay what was called
a hotel or a motel then Airbnb came
around and a lot of people said wow I
don't need to stay at a hotel anymore I
don't need to pay all sorts of fees I
can you know just say in some guy's
house or his apartment maybe he's got an
extra apartment and I'll just pay him
and I can use all of his facilities it's
kind of fun and it's a little cheaper
and it's wow this is cool but then
Airbnb started adding cleaning fees and
started adding this fee and that fee and
putting limits on how you could use it
and what time you checked in and all of
a sudden it didn't seem to be such a
great value anymore and so people
started returning to hotels and motels I
could see the same thing happening for
homeschooling if homeschooling is not
driven by an ideological or religious
motive if it's just because people got a
little freaked out during Co and they
lost some respect for the teacher unions
and they saw some weird stuff their kids
were being taught but they don't deeply
object to it they just thought it was
kind of weird and if they just they kind
of grow these homeschools from their
homes to their communities to these
miniature schools and all of a sudden
it's lots of different families at a
certain point you just going to you've
just created a small school and you're
just going to go back to the old kind of
schooling unless you've got a strong
ideological motive or religious motive
for it if you've got if you've got a a
strong driver why you're not going to
send your kids to a public school or
even many of the private schools are
infected that I think is where it's
going to persist so it will have been
mainstreamed it will be more diverse it
will be in all parts of the country it
it
homeschooling is the way that people
were schooled for most of human
history the notion of widespread public
school that's the experiment that's the
new thing so homeschooling is going to
be mainstreamed but if people lose the
the strong motiv ations for why they
would
homeschool at a certain point they'll
Pro those those groups will probably
just return to the regular old public or
private schooling Method Man that was a
good clip huh now you got to ring the
bell you got to subscribe to the Michael
NS YouTube channel we'll see you next
time